.
CARLEY: SURE YOU DO.
STEVE: THANKS, CARLEY.
IT'S A DEMOCRATIC FREE FOR ALL
WHILE MANY AMERICANS WAIT FOR
THEIR COVID VACCINE PATIENTLY.
WHITE HOUSE IS READY TO GIVE
AWAY SHOTS TO ILLEGAL MIGRANTS.
LISTEN.
>> WELL, CERTAINLY THE MORE
PEOPLE WHO ARE VACCINATED,
WHETHER THEY ARE UNDOCUMENTED OR
NOT, THE SAFER WE ARE AS A
COUNTRY.
THAT'S CERTAINLY THE PRESIDENT'S
POINT OF VIEW.
STEVE: IT'S NOT JUST THE BORDER
AS HOMELESS RESIDENTS IN SEATTLE
ARE BEING PUT IN FEMA FUNDED
HOTELS AND BEING GIVEN COVID
SHOTS AS WELL WHILE YOU WAIT.
OUR NEXT GUEST JUST RETURNED
FROM SEATTLE ON MONDAY WHERE HE
SAW THE CITY'S PROBLEMS
FIRSTHAND.
HERE WITH REACTION FOX NEWS
ANALYST LAWRENCE JONES.
LAWRENCE, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> HAPPY GOOD FRIDAY, STEVE.
STEVE: THANK YOU, YOU AS WELL.
LAWRENCE, IT MAKES PERFECT
SENSE, IF THE WHITE HOUSE IS
GOING TO LET MIGRANTS COME ON IN
BECAUSE THERE IS AN OPEN DOOR,
WHY NOT GIVE THEM A SHOT BEFORE
AMERICANS?
>> YEAH, IT'S KIND OF DISGUSTING
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT.
LOOK, WE WANT TO BE CHARITABLE.
WE WANT TO BE A GIVING NATION.
WE WANT TO HELP THOSE THAT ARE
LESS FORTUNATE.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN YOUR
OWN COUNTRY THAT HAVE NOT GOTTEN
THE SHOT, WHEN THERE IS SUCH A
SURGE, WHEN THERE ARE SO MANY
LINES TO GET THE SHOT, I THINK
IT'S A SLAP IN THE FACE OF THOSE
AMERICAN CITIZENS THAT HAVE BEEN
PATIENTLY WAITING FOR THE
VACCINE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK WE GOT TO GET
TO THE ROOT CAUSES OF THIS.
YESTERDAY, WHEN I WAS CO-HOSTING
"THE FIVE," I THINK I SAID THAT
WE HAVE TO HAVE TWO WEEKS TO
SLOW THE SURGE.
THERE'S A PROBLEM AT THE BORDER,
A PROBLEM OF BIDEN'S OWN MAKING
BECAUSE HE HAD INCENTIVES THERE
AND THAT'S ONLY GOING TO CAUSE
US TO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO PASS
OUT THIS FREE STUFF BECAUSE, AS
YOU KNOW, EVEN IF YOU LET THESE
PEOPLE IN, THEY CAN'T WORK,
UNLESS THEY STEAL SOMEBODY'S
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
STEVE: WELL, EARLIER I WAS
TELLING FOLKS THAT NEW YORK
STATE LAWMAKERS ARE GOING TO --
IN A $2 BILLION FUND GIVE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TO
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
SO, YOU KNOW, YOU JUST COME ON
IN TO THE COUNTRY AND NEW YORK
STATE WILL PAY YOU UP $28,000.
>> THEY WONDER WHY THEIR DEBT IS
OUT OF CONTROL RIGHT HERE IN NEW
YORK AND WHY THE TAXES CONTINUE
TO RAISE.
STEVE, I THINK THE THING THAT
AMERICANS FEEL IS YOU ARE DOING
THIS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC.
I MEAN, BUSINESSES ARE SHUTTING
DOWN IN NEW YORK AND NOW YOU ARE
HANDING OUT GOODIES TO
ILLEGAL -- I MEAN IT'S ABSURD TO
ME.
STEVE: ALSO, LAWRENCE, THAT'S
ANOTHER REASON WHY IF YOU ARE,
YOU KNOW, YOU ARE IN A PLACE AND
YOU ARE LOOKING TO LOOK, I LIVE
IN THIS TERRIBLE COUNTRY, THERE
IS GRINDING POVERTY IT'S GOING
TO GO TO THE UNITED STATES, I
WILL GET A SHOT AND I'M GOING TO
GET $28,000 FROM NEW YORK STATE
PLUS WHATEVER ELSE I CAN GET
ARE.
IT WOULD NOT SURPRISE ME,
LAWRENCE, GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE
KNOW THAT THE CONVENTION CENTERS
ARE SUPER SPREADER EVENTS, IT
WOULDN'T SURPRISE ME IF THERE IS
A PLAN IN THE WHITE HOUSE OR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ONCE THEY LET
THE MIGRANTS IN, BEFORE THEY SAY
OKAY, GO WHEREVER YOU WANT TO
GO, CALL YOUR AUNT OR WHOEVER
PHONE NUMBER YOU HAVE GOT, WE
WILL GIVE YOU THE J AND J SHOT
BEFORE YOU GO JUST SO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT IT.
BUT, ONCE AGAIN, ASIDE FROM --
THIS IS SPECULATION, BUT, THEY
WOULD ONCE AGAIN JUMP THE LINE
AHEAD OF SO MANY AMERICANS WHO
HAVE BEEN WAITING PATIENTLY,
LEGALLY HEAR IN THE COUNTRY.
>> I THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO HAVE
TO GET THEIR MESSAGING RIGHT.
MODERATE JOE IS REQUESTING TO
HAVE TO PICK WHAT SIDE IS HE ON?
LOOK, AGAIN, THE ONE -- AS
CHARITABLE AS AMERICANS ARE.
WHEN YOU START PUTTING OTHER
PEOPLE BEFORE THEM, THEN THEY
GET A LITTLE UPSET ABOUT THAT
AND RIGHTFULLY SO LIKE I SAID AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE SEGMENT,
THERE ARE AMERICANS WAITING FOR
A SHOT.
APPARENTLY THERE IS A LINE AND
DIFFERENT GROUPS THAT CAN GO.
WHEN YOU START PUTTING OTHER
GROUPS BEFORE.
IT BECOMES A PROBLEM.
SAME PROBLEM IN SAN FRANCISCO.
PEOPLE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO THE
MIGRANTS GETTING IN PERSON
EDUCATION BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING WRONG.
IT WAS THE PARENTS THAT SENT
THEM ON THIS TREACHEROUS
JOURNEY.
THE FACT THAT THEIR KIDS CAN'T
GET IN PERSON LEARNING IS WHY
PEOPLE ARE FURIOUS.
STEVE: AND, OF COURSE, WE WANT
AS MANY PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY TO
GET THE SHOT AS POSSIBLE.
IT'S JUST A QUESTION OF